so my podcast is only gonna work if I
get guests on the show how the hell am I
gonna get guests on my show so my
podcast is only gonna work if I've got
people to speak to you so how am I gonna
find gas and how do I sort get them
interested in incoming my podcast etc so
let me show you sort of how I've done
him on what I've done so far so what
what I've really got in my favor is that
I've got this recruitment blog so the
first thing that I did was reach out to
the people who actually did a guest post
or my recruitment blog so I reached out
to them and sort of said I'm thinking
about doing this podcast I'm really
excited about it would you thing would
you be have to get involved etc so first
things first is you're going to have to
be proactive you're going to have to
message people you're gonna have to use
your social so you should armed sure
you'll be on other social you think
about doing a podcast so get people's
forts and one thing that I did is well
actually wish I haven't shared is that
before I really decided right on the
start a podcast was on my Twitter I
actually started a blog which not a blog
sorry a poll and I started the poll and
said if if there was a recruitment
specific podcast would you listen to it
and it didn't get loads of votes I think
it got around sort of 15 or 20 but I
think basically all of them voted yes
and one person voted nine so that was
enough for me but what I'm trying to get
is that you can actually be proactive so
you never get down in people's DNA after
the mess of people on Twitter you have
to tweet them and also be bit smart
about it your what was gonna really help
and what I've sort of tried to do is
speak to people who may have a bit of
influence themselves speak to people who
are active on social because you want it
to be just as much for the guests as you
do for for you or see in your podcast so
I've already I've always spun in that
way when I've reached out to people
they're always always give
opportunity and always give them an
opportunity to sort of plug in what they
got going on at the moment what they're
excited about and I think that's
important when they're taking time out
of their day to obviously have a
conversation review on your podcast so
basically be proactive enough to get
messaging people would be a bit smart
about to reach out to people that you
think would be interested because they
did a lot on social or have a bit of
influence that might help you and make
sure it's just just as much for them as
it is for you as well and one last point
which I sort of made a bit of a pivot
when I was reaching out to people was
when I reached out to people I said how
long is it gonna take how many how much
time do I need etc and especially
recruiters we're busy with so so [ __ ]
busy so what I decided to do which has
really worked and the feedback we've got
is now a lot better is that I'm gonna
make here a 15 max 20 minute
conversation if it goes over that that's
okay and but we're not reaching out to
people and going right I need 15 minutes
your time then people look more in
contact because a lot more people have
50 minutes to spare so how how are you
going to get people on your podcast is
being proactive keep messaging people
and also just be a bit smart about it
and make sure that what value given to
them by them coming your podcast and all
that sort of stuff so that's what I've
done and what I wanted to share in terms
of how I get guests and how I get them I
wanted to come on the show
[Music]